(jappements)
- La rue s'appelle Ukraine
et elle mène tout droit vers
la frontière.
À moins d'un kilomètre,
la Russie prend fin.
Ici, il n'y a pas de soldat,
ni de char en vue.
Mais beaucou b beaucoup de
va-et-vient.
Vladimir et son fils sont venus
de Lougansk, le plus proche des
deux territoires séparatistes
de l'Ukraine, pour faire
le plein de denrées.
Ils ont un passeport russe,
maintenant, mais ils clament
haut et fort leur indépendance.
"Nous, à Lougansk, n'allons
attaquer personne, dit-il,
la gorge nouée. Nous ne voulons
qu'une chose :ststst vivre
en paix."
À côté, Yevgenia n'en demande
pas plus. Elle aussi e
de passage pour quelques heures
en Russie, le temps de ramasser
un colis de chez Zara et de
faire quelques emplettes
avec son ami, parce,e,e,
de leur côté, c'est cher et
il n'y a plus grand-chose
à acheter.
Il est russe; elle est
une fière ukrainienne et
appréhende une autre guerre.
"Je suis terrifiée, dit-elle.
En 2014, j'étais en cavale
pendant des mois pour échapper
aux combats avec mes enfants et
j'ai tellement peur que ça
recommence."
Même si elle n'a aucune idée
de l'ampleur du déploiement
russe ou des intentions exactes
du Kremlin.
Des villes comme celle-ci, sur
la frontière avec l'Ukraine,
il y en a des centaines. Et
même si on sait que les troupes
sont là, elles sont en retrait,
elles sont à des centaines de
kilomètres au nord à Voronej,
au sud à Rostov-sur-le-Don.
On peut pas s'en approcher,
on peut pas les filmer. Et pour
les gens qui habitent la région,
l'idée d'une attaque est
tout simplement impensable.
"Des soldats, je n'en voit pas,
j'en n'entend pas", dit
Vladimir, qui vit à 800 mètres
de l'Ukraine.
"C'est un complot de l'Occident
et de l'OTAN pour nous diviser
de nos frères ukrainiens."
Comme tant d'autres Russes,
il croit que son pays est
menacé.
- Leonid Pereshelin croit
lue e e e e e Vladimir Poutine
a raison d'exiger que l'Ukraine
soit exclue de l'OTAN à tout
jamais.
Il est chef des Cosaques de
la région, les plus patriotiques
de tous. "Mais, pitié, dit-il,
pas de guerre."
"Laissons l'Ukraine
tranquil e e e e e elle-même.
Ils sont nos frères slaves et
que Dieu leur donne la paix."
Mais, si la Russie attaque,
comme le craint de plus en plus
l'Amérique, si la guerre éclate,
peu importe qui la provoque,
Vitaly dit qu'il se ba
aux côtés des Russes.
Mais la plupart d'un côté comme
de l'autre de la frontière
n'y croient pas, ou encore,
préfèrent tout simplement
ne pas y penser.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, dans la région de
Rostov en Russi